[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
you may be offended by the court's
process but that is the court's process
we detail the final motions leading up
to friday's opening statements in the
trial of the men accused of killing
ahmad arbor and claims of sabotage on
the set of alec baldwin's rust could it
be true numerous mistakes were made
across the production plus the biden
administration sets a deadline for a
coveted vaccination rule we examine the
legality of the requirement and later
hear from the defendant kyle rittenhouse
himself there's somebody heard i'm
running into harm's way that's why i
have my rifle because i need to protect
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm brian ross in for brian
buckmeyer who's in georgia covering the
trial of the men accused of killing of
mount arbory and with me here in new
york is co-host terry austin well
opening statements are set to begin on
friday in that georgia trial on thursday
the judge heard motions from both sides
gregory and travis mcmichael and william
roddy bryant all face charges of malice
murder felony murder and aggravated
assault for the shooting of the 25 year
old jogger prosecutors say that the
father and son gregory and travis
mcmichael followed arbory in their
pickup truck as he ran near his home in
georgia back in february of 2020. travis
mcmichael shot and killed aubry claiming
self-defense brian followed along in his
own vehicle recording on his phone the
trial is being held in a courthouse in
glenn county georgia that's where our
own brian buckmeyer joins us now live
and brian we're just getting word that a
selected jury has dropped out of the
trial due to health issues
absolutely brian one perspective juror
came out because of back issues and so
one of the alternates came in this
alternate the most rememberable or
memorable point of what she said during
jury selection was i just wonder why
they didn't call a cop instead of doing
what they did but as we continued as you
said many motions were argued today some
were decided some the judge will give a
decision before tomorrow's opening
statements the judge decided that
portions of brian's video will be played
in opening statements the definition of
burglary will come straight from the
penal law that's attached to the
citizens arrest defense and that the
video of the aftermath of the death of a
mod aubry will come in but the small
amount of thc in arborist system is not
coming in the big things that the judge
will decide tomorrow is whether or not
aubry's probation record will come in
and whether or not the vanity plate on
the of the old georgia flag with the
confederate flag will come in those will
be decided tomorrow the arguments over
preliminary charges though at times got
a little heated but judge womley kept
the trial on track
you're moving pages
okay mr hogue i'm not sure what you're
trying to do here but
i just want to make an argument to the
court with your full attention okay the
court
is listening
to your argument
i am going through the brief
that you filed so i can follow and pick
up in the brief
these arguments as you make them so i
can see what facts you're relying upon
what case law that you have just to make
sure that i'm clear about the argument
the court's process
you may be offended by the court's
process but that is the court's process
you can continue
so brian what are the arguments about
that vanity plate of drafts mcmichael
being shown
so it's interesting this really goes to
the heart of the self-defense what's in
the mind of travis and gregory mcmichael
specifically travis whose vehicle had
that vanity plate on it and a mod arbory
the prosecution's arguing that it's
clear that he turned around and saw the
front of travis mcmichael's
truck and therefore an individual
looking at not only a truck barreling
down at them with two individuals in it
but also that vanity plate would have a
mindset to turn and run because of what
the connotation of that vanity plate had
the defense is arguing that you should
not be able to do that because that is
too uh prejudicial but again the
prosecution came back and said he chose
to put it on his uh vehicle so he chose
to allow others to see what his belief
was when it came to that vanity plate
and brian what's the scene like there
outside the courthouse there in glen
county georgia
so it's quiet today brian but earlier
today around two o'clock in the
afternoon there was actually a march of
about 50 people marching up across the
street where the courthouse is and into
the community stopping at a mod arboret
mural and other locations in the county
of glen and just chanting justice for
mod arbore talking about his life his
legacy and searching for justice in this
case
brian buckmeyer in georgia
thank you brian buckmeyer
on to other top legal news minneapolis
voters this week overwhelmingly rejected
efforts to overhaul the city's police
department
the vote came nearly a year after and a
half after the murder of george floyd
the first initiative to change policing
in the city that was put to a vote and
then failed although minneapolis
residents have been largely outspoken as
proponents for the defund the police
movement 56 percent voted to keep things
as they are
since the 2020 murder of floyd by a
minneapolis police officer eradicating
and reforming the police department has
been a controversial topic opponents of
the plan cited a lack of specific plans
for their rejection of essentially
putting the minneapolis police force out
of business
across the world in australia a family
is reunited with their four-year-old
daughter after she was abducted from a
campsite last month
what's your name
what's your name sped up
my name is claire
australian police say four-year-old cleo
smith went missing on october 16 from
the campsite where she was staying with
her family cleo was found early
wednesday morning locked in a house
about 30 miles away from where she was
abducted officers on the scene say they
found cleo playing with toys in a room
where she was locked in for nearly three
weeks hundreds of officers searched for
the missing girl 36 year old terence
kelly was arrested on multiple counts
including forcibly taking a child under
16. he appeared in court on thursday
afternoon
still ahead on law and crime daily a
deadline is set by the byte
administration for employees to receive
the covet 19 vaccine what our legal
experts have to say about that mandate
but first was the rust movie set
sabotaged with live rounds of ammunition
and jeanette levy has the latest from
the attorneys for the armorer on the set
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charge will now stand
trial for live galil gabo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
[Music]
and welcome back the husband of rust
cinematographer helena hutchins has
hired a lawyer week after she weeks
after she was killed on the set by alec
baldwin and now attorneys for the film's
armorer suggest someone may have tried
to sabotage the movie with live
ammunition law and crimes anjanet levy
has the latest
brian hannah gutierrez-reid was the
armorer on the set of rust and her
lawyers are now doubling down on that
bold suggestion that someone who was
upset about working conditions on the
set may have brought in some live
ammunition now gutierrez reid's lawyers
concede that she is the person who
loaded the revolver used by alec baldwin
that day when he shot and killed helena
hutchins as he practiced drawing the
weapon by all accounts gutierrez reid
had given the gun to assistant director
dave halls who then handled it to alec
baldwin gutierrez reid's lawyers say
that she provided gun safety training to
the actors including alec baldwin in a
statement jason bowles wrote never in a
million years did hannah think that live
rounds could have been in the dummy
round box who put those in there and why
is the central question she always
inspected the rounds she did again right
before handing the firearm to mr halls
by spinning the cylinder and showing him
all of the rounds and then handing him
the firearm
steve wolf is an armorer with decades of
experience he explained how to tell the
difference between dummy and live rounds
you really more hear the difference but
visually from the side they look the
same from the front importantly they
both look like live ammo on the back you
can see that this one has a primer which
has been dimpled this primer has already
been fired so that it's inert
and then if you shake them nothing on
this one because it's got gunpowder
and you can hear the bbs inside this one
where i've replaced the powder
with bb so that i can hear that it's
not a live round
and then this can be placed into a gun
and
the gun can be fully operated and
nothing will happen
now wolf says it's the armorer's job to
check that ammunition to inspect it to
make sure that it's not a live round and
he said that the weapon that day should
have been handed directly from gutierrez
reed to alec baldwin not to dave halls
as the middleman
brian let's bring back co-host terry
austin we're also joined by legal
analyst mike krabotix
mike this case has badly shook the movie
and tv industry there's talk of major
reforms and changes in handling firearms
on films and film sets will that be
enough to solve this thing
this is such an intriguing case because
the investigation is really going to
have to start from square one and follow
logic of how this happened i still can't
understand why in this day and age with
so much computers and things of that
nature that can make replicas that why
this even becomes a question on a movie
set that you would have a gun that could
even be operable where this could happen
i think that's a major reform that needs
to take place
and terry there are reports the firearms
were left unattended for at least two
hours before the incident does the
production company potentially face
civil liability because of that very
fact
they absolutely do the question is
whether or not it was negligent to leave
those props unattended and the
production company is responsible for
that and in fact if there was sabotage
here that means that they might have
been negligent for leaving those arms
unattended and the question is was there
duty of care was that duty of care
breached did someone get injured or in
this case was someone killed and was it
as a cause of the breach of that duty
and i think that a plaintiff the family
here of the person who died could make
an argument that there was a duty it was
breached and they are owed some civil
liability there and anjanette levy what
are detectives saying about those claims
of potential sabotage explosive
yeah they are explosive claims and i
should mention uh that jason bowles the
attorney hasn't offered any evidence to
back that claim up
so it's a very bold claim and it's
really
ruffled a lot of feathers out there i
reached out to the santa fe county
sheriff's office to see what they had to
say about this claim i received a very
curt email back that said no comment so
this investigation is ongoing it's a
criminal investigation and both the
district attorney and the
sheriff there in santa fe county have
said it's far too early to determine
whether anyone will be charged
and whether
what charges would be filed should
charges be filed brian
and jeanette thank you all
coming up on law and crime daily the
contentious case of wisconsin versus
kyle rittenhouse heats up as testimony
continues into day three
plus a ruling from the byte
administration that sets a due deadline
to require millions of americans to be
vaccinated our analysts break down the
legality of this rule still ahead
[Music]
and welcome back the biden
administration has announced a january
2022 deadline for vaccination
requirements that could affect 100
million workers island crime daily first
reported in september the biden
administration announced a vaccine
mandate for private businesses with a
hundred or more employees along with
certain health care workers and federal
contractors they'll all be required to
receive a full covet 19 vaccination or
to be tested for covid at least once a
week now white house officials say the
deadline for being fully vaccinated has
been extended to january 4 2022 after
the holidays the new rule would require
paid time off for employees to receive a
vaccination but employers don't have to
pay for the weekly testing if employees
opt out of the
vaccine terry pretty contentious when
that mask mandate came in now a vaccine
mandate what do you make of this it's a
growing number of vaccination mandates
across the country what are the courts
saying about the legality of this so far
well frankly so far the courts are
saying it is legal to mandate this sort
of requirement look the requirement that
biden is doing right now is under osha
osha covers everyone basically other
than whether you're self-employed or if
you are a family member of a farm worker
so it covers everyone and frankly the
mandate could have covered employers who
have people under 100 employees as it is
it's only those who have over 100
employees so i think that they are also
allowing religious exceptions and
exceptions for medical conditions so
with those place in place i think that
it's going to be upheld in the courts
and i think that we'll be allowed to
have this mandate go forward even with
many people who are currently objecting
to it so mike it appears to be legal but
employers are required to provide paid
time off for employees to get the
vaccine but not required to pay for
weekly covet testing for those who don't
get vaccinated what's the theory of that
does that make sense from a legal point
of view
well i think it does because obviously
the supreme court this is not the first
time the supreme court has dealt with
this they dealt with a pandemic in 1905
when they said vaccinations were okay
were okay to be mandated and didn't
violate anyone's constitutional right in
1922 when they had to do with children's
vaccinations i think what this
law is saying is that as a community we
have to take care of one another and if
one of those things is to defend against
a pandemic or an epidemic sort of
disease then the government can do it
and i think what they're saying is if
you don't want to get vaccinated and
you're going to put others at risk then
the responsibility on you as an
individual is to pay for those testings
because we're offering to pay for
something that will guarantee protection
all right mike and terry thank you so
much turning now to virginia where
witnesses testify about what they
experienced the night of the violent
uprisings in the unite the right rally
in charlottesville virginia
the so-called unite the right rally
happened back in august 2017 when white
supremacist groups gathered to
demonstrate in charlottesville
all this was in response to the removal
of confederate symbols by local
governments that followed the charleston
church shooting in 2015.
a self-identified white supremacist
rammed his car into a crowd of counter
protesters one woman died and dozens of
others were injured the first witness
was a counter-protester who said that
the event left her physically and
emotionally scarred saying she was
struck by the car and flipped over the
car that was speeding down the street
the trial is said to last until november
19th
when we come back the contentious trial
of accused kenosha shooter kyle
rittenhouse
it's what the judge calls the most
divisive case in the country right now
will take you inside the wisconsin
courtroom after this
[Music]
and welcome back thursday marked day
three what's proving to be the
fast-paced trial of wisconsin versus
kyle rittenhouse
eighteen-year-old rittenhouse faces
multiple charges including first degree
murder reckless murder and attempted
murder following the august 2020
shootings in kenosha wisconsin
prosecutors say rittenhouse shot and
killed joseph rosenbaum and anthony
huber and injured a third man ridden
house team argues the defendant was
acting in self-defense
at the time of the shootings rittenhouse
was 17 years old after a speedy jury
selection on monday the highly
anticipated trial began the following
day the jury heard two days worth of
testimony from state witness corey
washington who live streamed the
shooting to social media
he just seemed like he was young and
like he didn't know exactly like what
was going on and because he was smoking
so much and he
again the if he didn't have the gloves
on maybe i wouldn't have noticed as much
but i just don't know why like in the
situation
why you would have gloves on maybe
there's some technical reason or
something that you might know but to me
that's just what stood out to me okay
not saying that i felt like oh this is a
guy that's gonna go around and
mow a bunch of people down or anything
like that i just was like oh that's
interesting let me take a note of that
and
when he ran by i was like oh i went in
my rolodex in my head like oh i remember
this guy from before
washington spoke to the fact that he
made note of written house that night
and followed him on his live stream
video
since opening statements the jury has
seen an extensive selection of social
media videos including interviews with
the defendant himself
people are getting injured and our job
is to protect this business and part of
my job is to also help people if there's
somebody hurt i'm running into harm's
way that's why i have my rifle because i
can protect myself obviously
[Music]
and uh what about these other folks
obviously there's some other people who
are armed as well
gotcha
and then uh what about these guys up on
the roof your job is to provide
overwatch to protect me also gotcha
they're protecting everybody i'm
dropping to each other
microbiotics the judge in this case has
called it the most divisive case in the
country right now people on both sides
are very passionate as you can see what
could that mean for a jury's
deliberation as they think about all the
emotions here
well listen we we have to re we have to
rely upon jurors to live up to their
oath they need to get out of the
mindset of being political and having
preconceived notions they have to listen
to all the evidence in this case and put
aside whatever their personal beliefs
are and see exactly what caused this
incident that's what they need to do
terry the jury's seen a number of video
clips as we've seen here during the
trial uh the use of these videos is it
being effective you think
i do think it's being effective brian
but i will say some of that video is
very difficult to see it helps when the
actual videotographer is on the stand
and is going through the video and
telling us what we're looking at so the
jury can understand that and that
witness that we saw kerry washington he
was very effective and i thought that he
was credible he was explaining to the
jury what they were looking at and
making them understand what was actually
happening that night and i think when
you can do that it's very helpful to see
the video these days juries want to see
and not just here it can be
gut-wrenching as well though right
absolutely all right well thank you for
joining us here on long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you